[Música]
este 15 de abril se cumplieron 10 años
del atentado en la maratón de Boston y
la fecha fue conmemorada con varios
homenajes sobrevivientes socorristas y
miembros del público se reunieron en la
línea de meta y guardaron silencio
mientras sonaban campanas de una iglesia
cercana el atentado dejó tres muertos y
264 heridos
al menos 12 presos perdieron la vida en
medio de enfrentamientos dentro de una
prisión de Ecuador la fiscalía confirmó
que los hechos ocurrieron en la cárcel
del litoral la más grande y poblada del
país esto Sólo dos días después de que
seis reos aparecieron ahorcados en el
mismo centro ampliamos desde quito
el presidente de Cuba Miguel Díaz canel
explicó en una locución televisada las
causas de la nueva crisis energética en
la isla la falta de combustible ha
generado malestar entre los cubanos que
ya enfrentan largos apagones y falta de
transporte público
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos este 15 de abril se
cumplieron diez años del atentado en la
maratón de Boston que dejó tres personas
fallecidas y 264 heridas durante la
jornada Se realizaron conmemoraciones en
la bolstone Street de la ciudad donde se
ubica el Monumento a las víctimas así
como en otras partes de la urbe la
alcaldesa de Boston Michelle alentó a
los ciudadanos a llevar a cabo sus
propios actos de recuerdo
el drama del atentado aún su accidente
en el ambiente de la maratón que tendrá
lugar este lunes en el siguiente informe
de Andrés doncell recordamos los hechos
acaecidos hace una década
la maratón más antigua de Estados Unidos
[Música]
Boston acoge desde 1897 uno de los
eventos más importantes del país la
carrera se lleva a cabo en un día de
fiesta y es un símbolo Nacional de
alegría y fraternidad
pero la edición de 2013 fue diferente
[Música]
los explosiones en la línea de meta
convirtieron la celebración en una
tragedia
[Aplausos]
los artefactos detonaron dos horas
después de que el ganador cruzara la
línea de meta los más de 5.700
corredores aún no habían acabado
tras analizar la zona las autoridades
denominaron el hecho como un acto
terrorista y el FBI se hizo cargo de la
investigación
si buscaron intimidarnos aterrorizarnos
ya debería estar bastante Claro que
eligieron la ciudad equivocada para
hacerlo no aquí en Boston No aquí en
Boston Ese es el mensaje que enviamos a
los que llevaron a cabo esto y a
cualquiera que le haga daño a nuestra
gente sí los encontraremos Y sí
enfrentarán la justicia
los reportes iniciales apuntaron a dos
bombas de fabricación casera durante
días las agencias de inteligencia
analizaron miles de videos y cámaras de
seguridad identificando a dos
sospechosos tras difundir las imágenes
fueron identificados como
taberlandsarnaev y su carta arnaev
hermanos de una familia de origen
checheno residentes ambos en Estados
Unidos desde 2003
el 19 de abril los dos sospechosos
asesinaron a un policía y secuestraron a
un joven de origen chino que finalmente
pudo escapar y los delató en el
enfrentamiento con la policía uno de los
sospechosos murió y el otro huyó al día
siguiente fue encontrado escondido en un
pequeño bote
tras la captura del segundo sospechoso
las calles de Boston se llenaron de
júbilo
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque
cientos de personas protestaron en
varias ciudades del país a favor del
derecho al aborto y en contra de la
sentencia del juez de Texas contra la
comercialización de la píldora abortiva
mifepristona en Washington la
manifestación se centró A las afueras
del tribunal supremo luego de que la
máxima corte lo que dará temporalmente
la orden de ese juez de Texas la medida
del supremo llegó después de que el
departamento de Justicia presentara una
solicitud de emergencia pidiendo a la
corte intervenir en el caso
vamos a Ecuador porque la fiscalía
confirmó que doce presos perdieron la
vida en medio de enfrentamientos armados
dentro de la penitenciaría del litoral
ubicada en Guayaquil las autoridades
informaron que ya hay una investigación
para esclarecer responsabilidades los
hechos se presentaron Solo dos días
después de que seis reos fueron
encontrados ahorcados Gustavo Ortega
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplía
desde quito
la lucha entre bandas rivales el
narcotráfico ha dejado una semana
violenta en Ecuador riñas carcelarias
atentados con bombas y hasta alertas de
emergencias de la embajada de los
Estados Unidos en medio del peor momento
de crisis de violencia que actualmente
vive el país reconoció el ministro de
interior Juan Zapata el hecho más
reciente es la muerte de 12 privados de
libertad un enfrentamiento armado en la
penitenciaría del litoral ubicado en la
ciudad de Guayaquil la más violenta del
país la secretaría Nacional de atención
a personas privadas de la libertad
confirmó que los enfrentamientos
ocurrieron desde el día viernes y se
extendieron hasta la mañana del día
sábado entre los internos del cuatro de
los 12 aviones que conforman el centro
carcelario sin ofrecer mayor información
la fiscalía general del estado también
ha confirmado que realiza
investigaciones para identificar a los
responsables de la nueva masacre
carcelaria apenas días atrás otros seis
internos de la misma cárcel fueron
encontrados ahorcados en el centro
carcelario mientras que tres días
penitenciarios fueron asesinados durante
su periodo de descanso en la misma
semana otros tres recursos fueron
asesinados en la cárcel de la roca
ubicadas las inmediaciones de la
penitenciaria del litoral considerada de
máxima seguridad A eso se suma La ola
criminal de delincuencia como un
extorsiones robos secuestros que vive la
ciudad de Guayaquil desde el día lunes
hasta la fecha han muerto entre la
capital de la provincia de guayas y
Esmeralda al menos 34 personas de manera
violenta como resultado de la lucha de
territorios entre bandas del crimen
organizado Guayaquil se ha convertido en
uno de los principales puntos de tráfico
de la droga desde Sudamérica hasta
Europa y de los Estados Unidos y el
mayor punto de captura de droga luego de
los Estados Unidos y Colombia
en abu dhabi el presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva se reunió con
el presidente de miratí Mohamed sayed al
naián los líderes hicieron
énfasis especial en aumentar las
acciones en materia climática entre los
temas centrales estuvieron las energías
renovables la seguridad alimentaria y
otros asuntos de carácter económico
comercial y de desarrollo
vamos a Colombia porque el Estado Mayor
central la principal disidencia de la
antigua guerrilla de las FARC propondrá
el gobierno de Gustavo Petro que la mesa
de negociación que se llevará a cabo
Próximamente se instale en Noruega la
información se conoce en medio de la
reunión de una semana entre los
comandantes del grupo armado al tiempo
que se espera que este domingo se
anunciada la fecha en que arrancaran los
diálogos
en lo que parece ser una nueva
estrategia comunicativa el presidente de
Cuba Miguel Díaz canel compareció en
televisión para explicar las causas de
la nueva crisis energética en la isla la
falta de combustible ha generado
malestar entre los cubanos quienes
sufren entre otras dificultades largos
apagones y la falta de transporte
público los detalles los tiene Rafael
Pérez
una nueva crisis energética en Cuba el
presidente cubano Miguel díaz-canel
informó a los ciudadanos sobre el estado
crítico en el que se encuentran las
reservas de combustible para el normal
desarrollo de la vida diaria en la isla
el mandatario enrutó el problema los
países con los que tienen contrato para
el suministro al tiempo que destacó la
complejidad internacional que vive la
comercialización de carburantes Y eso ha
llevado ha propiciado ha ocasionado que
de un consumo entre quinientas y 600
toneladas diarias de gasolina
que el país
consume diariamente en estos momentos
estamos con coberturas de menos de
cuatrocientas toneladas diarias de
gasolina para todas las actividades del
país de manera diaria por estos días se
ha hecho como un observar largas filas
de automóviles que pueden durar días a
la espera de poder abastecerse a esto se
suman los graves problemas de
funcionamiento de las plantas
generadoras de energía debido a su
obsolescencia hemos tenido que depender
más de la generación eléctrica de la
generación eléctrica por la generación
distribuida que consumen lo fundamental
diesel por lo tanto una parte importante
del diésel que hemos dispuesto se ha ido
en generación eléctrica y por lo tanto
el país la economía sobre todo para el
transporte para otras actividades ha
dispuesto de menos combustible diésel en
este sector es donde más se ha visto
reflejada la falta de combustible debido
a que el transporte público es
ampliamente utilizado por los cubanos
cuatro y media de la mañana
seis de la mañana todavía estamos en la
parada para venir para el trabajo
ocho y media de la mañana hay veces que
llegamos hay veces que Llegamos temprano
depende de cómo esté la parada la falta
de un plan económico efectivo por parte
del gobierno el impacto del embargo
económico financiero y comercial de
Estados Unidos combinado con la crisis
económica internacional hizo que Cuba
entrara en una de las etapas más fuertes
de su historia solo comparable con el
llamado periodo especial de la década
del 90
el trofeo de la Copa Mundial de fútbol
femenino llegó a Haití un país cuya
selección estará por primera vez en esta
competencia que se disputará en
Australia y Nueva Zelanda entre julio y
agosto fue una visita Express en la que
el trofeo estuvo fuertemente escoltado
no se expuso al público en un gran
evento como ha sido el caso en otras
naciones dada la alta inseguridad en
Haití sino que fue presentado en la sala
de un hotel cercano al Aeropuerto
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]